"THE WASHINGTON POST"?
[LAUGHS]
THERE NAMED AFTER WASHINGTON
TOO.
JOINS US NOW, JIMMY.
THIS IS A PROBLEM FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
>> THIS IS MY FAVORITE THING IN
THE WORLD THAT THE IDEA THAT
THIS SNUCK INTO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" APPARENTLY
JEFF BEZOS WITH THE
BRICK-AND-MORTAR EDITOR SET UP
BUSINESS TOO BECAUSE THEY
SHOULD'VE CAUGHT THIS IT'S
ABSURD.
IT SUCH A CELL PHONE BUT I WANT
TO START AT THE TIPPY TOP MAN.
THIS WHOLE IDEA OF DECLARING WAR
ON DEAD PRESIDENTS DRIVES ME
CRAZY BECAUSE GEORGE WASHINGTON
BY THIS STANDARD OF THE DAY HE
LIVED IN WAS AN OUTSTANDING
HUMAN BEING, NUMBER TWO MY SON
IS NAMED LINCOLN.
I HAVE ONE KID TUCKER WE DECIDED
TO STOP READING FOR THE FIRST
REPORT CARD.
YOU KNOW WE'VE SHOULD PROBABLY
GET A DOG THIS ISN'T WORKING
OUT.
I'M A SON NAMED LINCOLN IN EVEN
HIS NAME IS CONTROVERSIAL NOW.
SO IS GOING BY HIS MIDDLE NAME
O.J.
[LAUGHS]
REALLY STICK WITH ME HERE
BECAUSE THIS DRIVES ME CRAZY.
EVERYONE THAT TRIES TO POINT OUT
OUR PAST IS ALSO HIGHLIGHTING
OUR PROGRESS WHEN THEY DO IT.
1821 IT WAS WHITES ONLY AT
GEORGE WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY AND
SURE IT WAS BUT NO NATION IS
WORK HARDER TO IMPROVE IT.
FAST-FORWARD TO 2022, THE ONLY
PLACE THAT'S LEFT THAT'S WHY
IT'S ONLY HIS COUNTRY CLUBS.
DOES NO OTHER PLACE WE ARE
EXCLUDING BLACK PEOPLE.
BUT THIS IS THE THING TUCKER.
LOCAL DEMOCRATS ARE CULTURAL ALL
ARSONISTS.
THEY LIKE TO FIND NEW FORMS OF
OPPRESSION THAT LITTLE SOCIETAL
FIRES SO THAT THEY CAN
EXTINGUISH THEM AND THEN CLAIM
VALUE AND VIRTUE BUT THE THING
IS THAT IF IT HELPS THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY THE
THING WITH THE BLACK COMMUNITY
IS ARE BEING PLAGUED BY FAILING
SCHOOLS AN ASTONISHING HIGH
RATES OF VIOLENT CRIMES.
NO WERE TONIGHT THERE'S A GUY
GETTING CRUSHED BY INFLATION AND
MUG FOR THOSE OVERPRICED GOODS
THANK ONLY SOMEONE COULD STOP
RENAMING A STATUE.
THAT'S WHAT DRIVES ME CRAZY MAN.
>> Tucker: THEY ONLY DESTROY
THE NEVER BUILD BUILD YOUR OWN
IMPRESSIVE COUNTRY OR SCHOOLS
THEY CAN'T, THEY CAN ONLY BREAK
THINGS OTHER PEOPLE.
>> IT'S SO MUCH EASIER TUCKER TO
SELL VICTIMHOOD TO THE BLACK
COMMUNITY THAT IS IS TO SELL
THEM PROGRESS.
THIS IS NEW, WHEN BARACK OBAMA
RAN FOR PRESIDENT WHAT WAS THE
MOTTO, YES WE CAN.
IF HE SHOWED UP NOW AND THE AGE
OF INCENTIVIZE VICTIMHOOD WITH
YES WE CAN THEY BE LIKE YO YES
WE CAN CHECK YOUR PRIVILEGE
WHITE GUY WHAT HE MEAN YES WE
CAN.
AND THAT'S THE PART THAT SO
STUPID.
>> Tucker: IT'S UNBELIEVABLY
STUPID AND GET BACK TO ME WHEN
YOU BUILD SOMETHING MOR